we're gonna shift gears now this half
hour and talk about this many experts
predicted at the start of the pandemic
that widespread self isolation would
lead to more cases of child abuse now
they believe cases are actually being
underreported calls the child abuse
hotline z' have gone down since stay at
home orders took effect by around 50% in
some states now forty welfare workers
who are on the frontlines protecting
children have submitted video diaries to
CBS News first on CBS this morning our
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
shows us in their words how the outbreak
is putting kids and workers at risk this
is our waiting room it's completely
empty the only reason I am here today is
because we have an emergency case coming
in in a little bit just got a call about
a child fatality in our area and it just
goes right along with the fact that this
is a perfect storm for child abuse since
the first known case of coronavirus hit
the United States only the most extreme
child abuse cases are being reported the
physical abuse cases that we are seeing
are kids that are being severely
physically abused and needing medical
treatment kids with broken bones kids
with visible bruises kids with head
injuries you have all these factors that
come into play you know nobody really
wakes up in the morning and says oh I
think I'm gonna kill my kid today you
know it comes from frustration and anger
and stress and that's when kids get hurt
children aren't coming into contact with
the people who would normally be the
ones who report the abuse that mandated
reporters the teachers the counselors or
even friends who then tell an adult
about what's going on parents are
struggling both with losing jobs putting
food on the table the stressors of home
schooling kids and all of that even
though a lot of people are staying at
home right now child abuse does not stop
and it's often hiding in these difficult
situations they're unique challenges for
child welfare workers this used to be my
kitchen table it's now a desk whether
working from home over here I've
transformed a little corner
into where I can take my virtual
sessions or meeting with children in the
field when you go fully facemask and
love the best try to touch me thing I'm
outside right now because this is where
I've met with some of my families over
the last couple weeks as we tried to
social distance since co19 we've had to
come up with unique ways to forensic we
interview kids we have things
jerry-rigged
so that we can set up a safe process
where interviewer sits and the child
sits and they communicate via a video
conferencing I just finished
interviewing a young child here at
Baltimore child abuse center using our
telephone zyk interviewing set up it was
extremely challenging the hardest part
about this whole thing is my family's
reaction
my partner's reactions to having to go
out into the field and expose myself to
the virus truth be told before I looked
at about a 15-minute argument
about whether or not I really needed to
go I myself was tested positive four
weeks ago and you know the experience
with people past and around me it was
just like you know scary it was
nerve-wracking so I can understand the
fear that my staff could have as far as
coming to work every day despite the
danger they're doing whatever it takes
to keep children safe for me it's not
even a question I have no problem
risking my life in order to help a kid
that's possibly being sexually abused I
can't really think of anything else in
this world that would be more than more
hospitals like Cook Children's in Fort
Worth Texas say they're seeing a number
of more of those severe cases of child
abuse since mid-march they say that
they've had at least nine of those cases
three of them Anthony ending in deaths
yeah Jericka we first we thank all those
child welfare workers for sharing their
stories and recording that for us very
hard stories to hear but very important
ones to hear thank you